je suis rentré en soirée s'est trouvé un
mot de ma mère disent en choeur
que si je voulais y avait des essais qui
se faisait pour un film d'elie jouac
j'ai su à l'épaule pour rigoler goût
mais j'avais eu
enfin je sais pas c'est en plus elle a
mis longtemps pour
entre le ton contre le taux j'ai fait
les décès le temps m'a dit que je serais
nom avait beaucoup de temps allongé
longtemps
[Musique]
et est ce que sur ce tournoi jeu là vous
vous êtes vous avez commencé à vous dis
ah ben oui au fond c'est ça que j'ai
envie de faire du mal on sait ce qu'elle
a à la fin de son âge est né j'ai
dessiné l'année en pension et j'ai un
peu oublié
et puis là dessus
la proposition de club j'ai décidé
d'aller en pension c'était c'était moi
je sais pas je sais pas pourquoi on peut
soit mes questions mais je sais pas je
vais peut-être
une manie
pour l'effrontée
c'est passé commande
justement comme été
ici il m'avait fait tourner des scènes y
avait pratiquement pas dialogue
et un mot ça s'était bien passé
pendant le tournage vous avez répété des
scènes avec notre mère par exemple
découvrir par exemple j'ai pas à la
maison à mon âge j'ai tourné en
extérieur pratiquement tout le temps
même quand on tournait près de paris
je savais pas je vais je n'ai pas envie
de rentrer chez moi mais vous avez envie
d'en faire votre métier
je sais pas c'est à chier ces liens je
faire autre chose ce que je voudrais
être coincé à sans rien
autre chose
je m'adresse à
odessa
comme quelque chose qui pourrait
remplacer
m'occuper de ce cas
ça prend pas toutes orges
et vous pensez pas que bon un jour ou
l'autre peut-être assez vite vous aurez
à trancher
je veux pas rater
le fait d'être actrice ou d'avoir été
actrice il n'y a pas quelque chose
d'inéluctable de définitif
fin dans ma tête
dans ma tête j'ai un avis mais que je
n'aimerais pas
ça vous ferait peur justement si les
choses étaient posées comme ça de
manière définitive
oui parce que j'aurais peur que sans que
ça marche pas qu'est ce que je fais
pendant le tournage vous alliez au rush
donc vous avez découvert le film à la
fin une fois montés et mixé
donc avec quel sentiment
vous chauffez la troupe à ce qu'on est
et
il n'y avait pas que moi qui étais dans
la salive et toute l'équipe
salon j'étais très gênée
mais
au fond de moi je crois que c'était
plutôt agréable que le fait qu'on ait
toujours que c'est désagréable de soi
je crois qu'au fond hier est toujours un
plaisir à voir ce qu'on a fait comme
sûrs
et vous vous êtes dit à ce moment là que
vous avez réussi votre cou non non pas
du tout
j'attendais les réactions naissance
le césar que vous avez eue pour pour
l'effrontée 86 est ce que vous vous y
attendiez un petit peu
vous étiez nominés dont vous aviez une
chance sur l'eau mais bien sûr
j'espérais
je voulais pas trop espérer
enfin
ça me connaît à la fois ctcc aurait
par rapport aux autres
quand vous avez entendu votre nom qu'on
sortait de l'envelope j'avais surtout
peur de perdre
je me demandais ce que je ferais si je
perdais et puis les nîmes a fait autant
peur
vous aviez préparé un petit compliment
et à ce moment là il n'y a pas eu non
plus dix parle pas d'un déclic là cette
femme et petite petite voix intérieure
qui vous aurait dit tiens
je suis sur la bonne voie
je suis sur la bonne voie on cherche les
chaussées
qu'est ce que vous faites sur un
tournage
entre deux prises entre le seul
souhait est que l'équipe j'aime bien
vous vous ennuyez pas alors
c'est comment temps tellement de
kobayashi c'est ennuyeux on s'ennuie oui
je sais j'ai ce point compté mais pas du
tout
vous parlez technique avec eux
oui ça m'intéresse
j'aime bien les extérieurs parce que il
ya toutes les filles le thème avec
l'équipe
c'est un peu triste alors quand on doit
se quitter quand le tournage est fini ah
oui
bisous quels sentiments c'est au moins
aussi affreux je peins on a quand même
passé deux mois ou plus ensemble en fin
de mois
et tout d'un coup de savoir que tout
sera terminé
c'est vraiment triste
et les actrices
ils sont celles que vous préférez
je sais pas
quand même beaucoup mais j'aime je
voulais et c'est triste et nîmes
en avant
oui ma muse actrice française d'avant
c'est pareil pour les acteurs ce qu'elle
savait où il avait quelque chose que les
actrices et acteurs d'aujourd'hui n'ont
plus d'avenir c'est
l'époque
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient je sais pas je
crois pas dire
ça me fait marrer
[Musique]